today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
so earlier this week republicans dragged
sally yates into a senate hearing to
investigate their continued conspiracy
theories about the michael flynn
investigation and it went so
poorly for them remember that sally
yates is the former deputy attorney
general she's criticized
the justice department's decision to
drop the prosecution against michael
flynn who is
as a reminder the former trump national
security adviser who had been
indicted so republicans have cooked up
all sorts of different conspiracy
theories many of which go through
sally yates and republicans control the
senate at least until january they
brought sally yates
in to testify via video conference and
it just went
so poorly for republicans i want to show
you a few clips
now she testified about how the obama
white house
first became alarmed about michael
flynn's behavior
that flynn was having secret discussions
with the russian ambassador before being
sworn in
he was talking to mike pence about
things that
really stunk to high heaven so yates
explains that
it was investigated plain and simple
there was really no
scandal there but of course republicans
have been
desperate and continue to be desperate
to claim that there was an obama
administration conspiracy
to take down trump that includes the
obama administration
illegally spying on the trump campaign
all of this different stuff they want to
claim that
it was investigative of abuse and much
more
but take a look at how badly this
imploded in their faces
sally yates facing a very hostile panel
of questioning from republicans
here's lindsey graham maybe one of the
most unhinged
brown-nosing trump sycophants trying to
play prosecutor
and he doesn't like sally yates's answer
so he keeps interrupting and
senator patrick leahy tells him hey
senator graham
just because sally yates is a woman
doesn't mean you have to keep it
interrupting her which is hilarious and
it kind of threw lindsey graham off for
a moment take a look
now let's talk about a january 5th
meeting
was the vice president there yes he was
okay did he mention the logan act
you know i don't remember the vice
president saying much of anything
miss me so you don't remember him
mentioning the logan act
no i don't did anybody mention the logan
act
i have a vague memory uh director comey
mentioning the logan act
okay what was he mentioning the logan
act about in what context
well that's i'm not sure if he mentioned
that
in the oval office meeting or in the
meeting that he what do you think about
that
mr chairman let her answer the question
just because it's a woman testifying
doesn't mean she has to be cut off yeah
thanks a lot
senator lee i really appreciate that
you're very constructive
so here's my question lindsey graham is
so
horrible and he does have a challenger
in a senate race i want to remind you
that jamie harrison is running against
lindsey graham
we could remove by we i mean the voters
of south carolina could remove lindsey
graham
that's an interesting race to follow and
maybe get involved in
continuing here's a video of ted cruz
saying when did you first learn that the
obama administration
was spying on the trump campaign yates
says that never happened
and ted cruz visibly flummoxed
um miss yates when
did you first become aware that the
obama administration was surveilling
the donald trump campaign
the obama administration was not
surveilling the donald trump
just a bizarre moment i mean this is
desperation
from these republicans and of course all
of this
is meant to distract from the disaster
after disaster after disaster that is
the current trump administration and ted
cruz
actually continued to propose things
that never happened
during his questioning of sally yates
and sally yates
continually had to continue putting him
in his place take a look at another
example
so if i's application is not
surveillance the fisa application was
for carter page
who was a former member of the trump
campaign at that point
so your testimony is that that the
investigation carter page had nothing to
do with the donald trump campaign
no i'm suggesting you asked me if we
were surveilling the campaign
you don't get it both ways is it the
campaign or not
senator i'm trying to give you what is
the accurate information here
carter page was a former member
of the trump campaign at the time that
the pfizer was initiated
and what was the reason for the fis on
carter page
there were a number of reasons first we
had gotten the information that i was
trying to point out here that the
russians had made the overture that they
wanted to be able to assist the trump
campaign
said it had nothing to do with the trump
campaign
i said that he was not a member of the
trump campaign
at the time that we initiated the visa
now the really sad thing is
that in republican circles they see
these same videos
and they see this as really brutal
questioning from ted cruz
that sally yates fell apart it's
semantic games it's
it's really a lesson actually in how the
right makes their arguments and it's a
lot of semantic games
and optics and i wish it didn't work but
it works
if you look at how republicans respond
to kaylee mcinanny's press briefings you
know kaylee comes out
and she scolds the media and then she
always has some
scripted walk out that is it like it
makes me
cringe when i see it but there are
people who love it
the vapid scripted walk-offs and the
attacks on media
many of us accurately see them for what
they are which are just completely
empty vapid meaningless optics but there
are republicans
who love it and donald trump jr will
retweet it as
kaylee owns the media and that's exactly
the same thing that happens with
briefings or with testimony like this
where
the questions lindsey graham is asking
the questions ted cruz
is asking the they are dumb leading
questions and sally yates has no choice
but to say that's not true that's not
true that's not true
but there is a contingent that says wow
she really fell apart let's look at just
a tiny bit more
cruz just keeps going here so when they
came to you
asking to surveil members of the trump
campaign
because of conduct they allegedly did
while members of the trump campaign
what due diligence did you do did you
press back at all you already told
senator kennedy you
just trusted the fbi you didn't ask
about their sources you did i mean what
due diligence did you do
before signing off on
what we now have significant reason to
believe
was a profound politicization of law
enforcement and intelligence
senator there was a tremendous amount of
process back and forth
between the lawyers in the national
security division and the fbi okay i
asked what you did not not other lawyers
what due diligence did you do you were
the one signing off on it
and and with respect to whether the
facts were accurate
in this instance so did you inquire
whether it was opposition research
funded by the dnc or hillary clinton
yes i did have a discussion about that
so it was hours of this stuff hours and
hours and it's like trying to squeeze
water from a rock it's like there's a
lake
where all the water is and that's the
disaster after scandal after
embarrassment of the trump trump
administration
they ignore the lake where you could
just go and drink the water
and instead they focus on pricking up
picking up rocks
and trying to squeeze water out of them
and pretending that the lake doesn't
exist then we'd better thank them
for trying to squeeze water out of a
rock it's uh it's pathetic
it's going absolutely nowhere but if
trump wins
in november you can expect a lot more of
this
the experiment of sending kids back to
school during a raging hundred-year
pandemic
by this administration has failed
and uh it has failed very poorly and i'm
not pleased to see this and to be clear
i wish it were possible to send kids
back to school safely right now i
it's become very popular among some on
the right to say the left wants to hurt
businesses the left wants to hurt
education
the left wants left doesn't care about
people's emotional health
all because they want to close close
close in order to hurt donald trump
i don't deny for a second that there are
tangible benefits
intangible benefits and psychological
benefits to getting kids back to school
i don't deny that many parents can't get
back to work unless their kids are back
in school
so i get it the considerations are
economic they're emotional they're
wide-ranging
when you have fifty thousand cases a day
fourteen hundred deaths a day
and we've already debunked the false
notion that kids can't catch the disease
or spread the disease
it just doesn't pass the sniff test that
this would work and case in point a
georgia second grader
tested positive on day one back in
school by day two
the classroom was closed the teacher and
students were quarantined for two weeks
and out of school
and there are many of these examples 260
employees
either tested positive or were exposed
in gwinnett county public schools in
georgia that's georgia's largest
school district hours after the first
day
in an indiana district last week the
county health department notified
greenfield
central junior high that a student who
had been in a bunch of classrooms all
over the school
in contact with teachers and students
helped uh
um was helping students i don't remember
the the exact details was all over the
school
tested positive for coronavirus and once
again caused a mass quarantine of 14
days
for everybody that they had been in
touch with we saw what happened in
israel
where they successfully dealt with the
virus crushed the curve i mean just
obliterated it
obliterated the curve open schools
and then things went backwards very very
quickly so
it's not inconceivable that states
uh could open schools some states could
open schools safely
maybe but a lot has to happen in order
to do that
first and foremost when we were down to
20 000 cases a day
every state started opening that was not
the time to actually start
opening as aggressively as happened
number two
i know that it's august but we still
don't have enough testing or fast enough
testing the testing is falling behind
the viral spread when we talk about how
much we test relative to other countries
remember that at this point
circumstances are so different in
countries
that in order to keep up with our level
of spread
we need dramatically more testing and we
need dramatically faster testing people
are often not hearing back for days
five to seven days in some cases a
travel blogger i know waited
20 days for his test results got them
the day before
he was going to a different state this
is the same issue we've been talking
about for a long time when it comes to
lots of types of businesses and
organizations and certainly schools
where people are even more crowded
together for hours all day
there's not an easy easy answer i i'm
not pretending this is simple i
get all of the reasons why we would want
to open schools but what we've seen so
far we have to be guided by the data
tells me the risks exceed the possible
rewards
by the spring semester early 2021 we
might have both
more effective treatments and vaccines
that are increasingly inoculating people
so to me that says let's do online in
the fall i'm not saying don't do it i'm
saying let's do it online
let's suffer through it my mom is a
college professor up until two days ago
they were planning on allowing
professors to teach in person if they
wanted to now my mom had already decided
to go fully remote
but because of what's happening now in
massachusetts which by the way is
nothing compared to what's going on in
some states
her university decided we're doing all
remote it sucks
but it makes sense it's a mess it's not
political masks should be worn it's not
political
it's too early to open a lot of things
it's not political
i'm so glad i'm not in a position of
having
to send kids to school or not and make
decisions about where they should be
i don't envy the parents i don't envy
the teachers or the administrators i'm
not pretending it's easy i get it
there's not a simple answer
but it's increasingly clear that the
safe answer is
you've got to do online in the fall and
increasingly it seems more and more
states are going in that direction let
me know what's happening in your state
uh let me know on twitter at dpakman and
remember
you can listen to the david pakman show
podcast every day
every weekday okay we take weekends off
on whatever
your favorite podcasting app is spotify
itunes
stitcher pandora it's quite a laundry
list it's almost
too easy to get the audio podcast but i
encourage you to do it
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are tracy
holly and victoria rodriguez
tracy and victoria thank you so much for
your support
i also want to thank mark ash who is
today's long time
sustaining member of the day mark's been
a member for almost five years
and you can someday be sustaining member
of the day it's down the line i admit
uh by grabbing a membership at
joinpakman.com
let's go to the phones at 617-830-4750
let's go first today to ronald reagan
who uh has been trying to get on for a
very very long time
and uh ronald what's going on today
well i don't know i don't know about
your framing i'm
trying to get on for a very long time i
mean i guess kind of well you've been
sending me tweets saying i've been
calling in i've been calling in sort of
stuff
well i wish you would follow me back
david i want to be friends with you
that's
the thing but oh okay so i've got a
couple
couple questions for you um you
announced the big
race to a million subscribers on your
youtube
with the majority report um so that's
completely that that so that was
at the time you asserted hold on a
second ronald
at the time you asserted that i had not
done that
i have since been pushed into a war
because sam fired a shot across the bow
saying that i was using bots
sure sure sure i mean i feel like it was
implied
i mean one does not race against himself
so i mean it's a race against the clock
okay um at the time
you guys were pretty close and now
you're you're really pulling away which
you deserve
tremendous credit for really and i
wonder do you think it's
yeah i mean you're at 917 and
and the majority reports at 9 10. i mean
they're
really struggling to keep up do you
think it's a a stamina issue for sam
cedar what tell me what you mean by that
well i mean you're just
you're churning out the content i mean
you can't be stopped you're
you're a literal content machine
and he kind of comes on and does his one
little show
per day and sometimes he has to have his
producers host the show so he's not even
really he's kind of phoning it in some
of the time
well listen the thing is sam is doing
more content than me most days
like sam does a three-hour show i do a
one-hour show so i think that what
you're saying is empirically wrong
oh okay yeah um
so you don't think it's a stamina issue
for sam then i have no evidence that
sam's lacking in stamina
okay so what do you think it is i mean
that you're you're just uh
you know really pulling away here it
doesn't even seem
it's hard to hold to call it even a race
anymore
i am not going to necessarily indulge
your characterization
and i don't know what's going on i mean
in my experience you know
we've had times where we'll get like 8
000 new subscribers in a month and i'm
just doing the same thing i'm doing my
show every weekday
and then we'll have a month like july
where we get
39 000 subscribers in a month and i'm
not doing anything different i mean i
think what is going on is
in general we're getting closer to the
election more people are interested but
in terms of any discrepancies between my
channel and other channels
i don't know what it is i think these
things kind of come in waves
david let me ask you a serious question
because um
i really like your show um i'm being
sincere
and i like your show a lot um
and so i posted about this and a lot of
people were
were trying to you know dunk on you or
whatever i'm not i'm not here for that
one thing that people were saying or
this came up a bunch of times is that
pacman was wrong about the coup in
bolivia and i don't know anything about
that
i didn't i wasn't paying attention i
guess to what you said at the time
and so i'm curious if you want to
respond to those people
who maybe have that to maybe have that
concern i being
i'm being totally sincere i'm not trying
to like start uh something but i'm
curious
um what that's all about you'd have to
ask them they i guess they'd have to
call in and tell me specifically what it
is they want me to
say or or whatever um if they're acting
in good faith
i'm glad to talk to them and you know as
i'm sure you know
many people in this space don't act in
good faith
and if that's the case i mean i would
tell them to call in because you're not
if you if you have a specific question i
could answer it but to say
respond to people whose comments i've
not seen and whose
arguments i don't know would be
difficult to do
no that's fair enough all right well
i'll tell people
i'll spread the number far and wide
please i would love to see your comments
so i can i can respond directly to it
but um
uh keep up the good work oh but i was
going to say it
i think that you guys need to hash out
some sort i mean there needs to be
stakes it can't just be somebody
get there and and then that's it so
um you know i i think
the the payoff should be uh the loser
has to do
sun's out guns out tank top shows for
a whole week you know i don't i don't
even um i don't even
own what i think is sometimes
colloquially and inappropriately
described as a wife beater
shirt and i know that that's a very
inappropriate term some people call it
an
a shirt or a male tank top i don't even
own
such a shirt so we'd have to first start
up a collection to even
get me such a shirt well that's not a
problem
that can be arranged good um all right
thanks david okay ronald i appreciate
the phone call wow
wow just a lot a lot happening there
let's go next to our caller from the
seven two zero
area code who's calling today from 720
hey david is that me yeah who's this
hi this is gabriel from colorado gabriel
from colorado what's on your mind today
so i know a little while ago it might
have been like half a year ago or
something at this point
you're asking about how to maybe i think
you're asking the audience for ideas on
how to maybe branch out into the spanish
speaking
sort of content creation area yeah
that was i do remember that and we
basically we
we evaluated all of the possibilities
and decided
i really need to reduce my workload by
about 30
and starting to do another show in
spanish was not going to allow me to do
that
so we've we've sort of gone away from
the idea
okay i did have a sort of low effort low
time commitment
idea yeah so so the idea is you record
the show as normal
and then you pick one topic or one story
from the show and just re-record it in
spanish you don't even edit it you just
like a daily one one like five to ten
minute upload in spanish
i think that'd be a pretty low effort
way to reach out to a whole new audience
and let me ask you this do i post it to
my english language
youtube channel or do i create a new
channel because there's sort of it's a
catch-22
if i post it to my existing channel
english speakers will be annoyed that
there's spanish content if i post it to
a new channel that channel won't have
any subscribers so nobody will watch it
well i was figuring you could grow your
spanish channel over time but it's like
a little side project if it doesn't work
no big deal if it does hey look at you
you know it's not a terrible idea i i
don't i don't think it's a terrible idea
to be perfectly frank
now i'm curious what's your interest in
this are you a spanish speaker or is it
more just an effort to reach out to the
spanish community
spanish speaking community i mean i i am
i am trying to learn spanish i'm kind of
doing a bad job but i just think it'd be
a great way to reach out
okay and honestly i think it'd be fun to
just listen to you talking spanish i
like it when you do it's kind of neat
all right well i think that you're if we
were to do it i think what you're
talking about it's sort of like the push
cart model i learned that
i i paid a lot of money for graduate
school where a teacher said
come up with a way to push cart test any
new business idea before you set up a
restaurant
you get a little food cart and you test
it as sort of the gist and i think
you're bringing up an excellent idea
yeah yeah sure all the
there for your consideration all right
thank you so much i appreciate it thank
you we'll talk to you very very soon
that's it really is an interesting way
to consider doing it we should look at
that
let's go next to our caller from the 724
area code who's calling today from 724
hello david yeah who's this
uh this is carlo from uh pa's 16th
district
um here we have we have a tarot
sorry we have a terrible congressman his
name is mike kelly
right and i feel like people
really underestimate the importance of
local elections i think you know people
focus way too much on like who's going
to be the president
but you know people don't really see the
importance and the value of
people who are representing you know
their local communities
uh i think that you were right in that
people tend to
particularly in the space of political
hobbyism and infotainment
people tend to spend a lot more time
following
political issues that may never affect
them directly
or will only affect them directly in
limited ways while ignoring the local
issues and i by no means i'm suggesting
anybody ignore
who is their senator or who is the
president but i think the right advice
is
understand that your day-to-day is going
to be affected by your city councillor
if you have a city councillor the mayor
of wherever you live etc
and we want to make sure that people
understand that and republicans do
understand this that's the crazy thing
they don't
necessarily make a big deal out of
promoting it they very quietly take over
school boards and city councils and they
get it and we need to get it as well
right and here i mean it's a pretty
conservative area but we do have
someone who is running against mike
kelly
her name is christy geneves um that's
g-n-i-b-u-s and i'm i'm just here to
reach out to people your audience
that you know get her name out there
please donate to her campaign because
here i mean mike kelly has a horrible
track record horrible voting record
he voted against the like every health
care bill
during this pandemic he voted against
and
he voted against the george floyd
justice and policing act as well
which just unacceptable his voting
record he's voted alongside trump
consistently so the plan is to get rid
of him so
i would just like to get christie's name
out there all right well
people should i i am not familiar with
her but i will look into it and i
appreciate you bringing it up
right pa 16th district thank you david
all right thank you by the way
appreciate the phone call thank you so
much yes many many races to get involved
in
let's go to our caller from the 407
area code who's calling today from 407
uh would that be me mr pacman yes who's
this
uh my name is liam i'm calling from
florida seventh
love it anyways i had a uh
kind of a my specific question
um i feel a lot of in
a lot of my discussions with more uh
right weaning people or just maybe even
center or even center left
they have a specific sort of commitment
to capitalism because they sort of um
which makalada have a conflation
with markets for whatever reason they
associate the idea of
capitalism equaling markets when they're
not necessarily the same thing
do you feel like um that's a um
big reason as to why people are so
adamant uh in your own interactions with
right wingers
as to why they don't want to uh change
that sort of uh
market system in other words that people
might like markets and they mistakenly
believe
that only in capitalism do markets exist
and thus they think they need to support
capitalism when you could for example
support something like market socialism
exactly because i myself i think that
there's no doubt that
you know the average the average person
probably is not super informed about a
concept like market socialism
i i actually do think that most
people if presented with
the the the basic framework of market
socialism which would be
socialized ownership but markets still
exist
i think a lot of people may not know
about it but if they did they still
wouldn't be for it
but i think that we would only know that
if people were aware of it and many
people are not so i don't think your
comment is
without merit um
well that's really the only question i
had uh thank you for your time mr paxton
all right thank you and please call me
david we don't need to be so formal on
this program
okay let's go next to our caller from
the 941 area code who's calling today
from 941
hi david this is william i'm from
florida william from florida what's
going on
hi david i really like your show i just
want to put that out there for right now
thank you um so my question's a little
broader
in spectrum um i uh i've recently gotten
into
small government politics just because i
work in substance abuse field
and we get a lot of governmental funding
and stuff like that um
now william i'm sorry to interrupt you
but do you mean
do you mean small government as in small
government concern
conservatism or just local politics do
you mean
just look local county politics oh got
it okay okay good good
good just mostly kind of i've kind of
had to just to learn where the money's
coming from
where it's flowing from stuff like that
to help clients get resources and things
like that
yep um but one thing that i've noticed
since the outbreak
is a lot of that funding has kind of
disappeared
and a lot of the resources um it seems
like people don't know where their
phones are
and uh and i was wondering do you think
this is a direct correlation
between what's going on in the
larger terms politically with trump and
all those things
um do you think that these things can be
related i know that that's a very
specific question
um we'll listen and uh and for the most
part i realize i live in a red state
the answer is probably different in
every
instance so there's no question if your
question is
is funding to specific programs you're
interested in being cut
because of trump the answer would
probably be
i have no idea unless we look into it
specifically and
probably not but where i think the more
direct connection is that is not getting
a lot of attention you know there's a
lot of
talk about if there's not if people are
unemployed
where do they get money to spend stuff
in the economy small businesses need
people coming in with money to spend so
we've got to get money to people either
through unemployment or through stimulus
the part that's being ignored is
directly related to what you're bringing
up which is
if the government is collecting
less revenue from payroll taxes
in states that have payroll taxes and if
there are
moratoriums on this or that or whatever
states have less money to then
redistribute back out to all sorts of
different programs now you'd have to
look at it at the state by state and
program by program level like in other
words
is there is is there a specific answer
in florida
i i just don't know you'd have to look
that up but certainly what people have
to understand is the state government
can only take in
reduced revenue for so long before they
are going to start saying we can't
afford to fund this program and that
program and that is certainly going on
right okay well that makes a lot of
sense um
i just like i said i've just seen over
time
um like i said i work directly with
clients i actually work in
a county jail and i work with inmates
rehabilitating them who have dealt with
substance abuse
i've dealt with substance abuse so we
we have a correlation there like we can
relate on those levels and so i get um
emotionally attached to these people a
little bit yeah and uh
which is part of my job um and then uh
and then i try to i try to connect them
to as many resources as they can to be
successful
upon exiting the gl system or the prison
system and so
it's just been kind of heartbreaking to
see like and i understand i get it when
you put it in terms like that as
in the government can't give us money if
they're not making any
you know um and so uh but that's i i
thank you for simplifying it to me
because like i said i'm new to these
things i never
before trump got elected i never thought
once about politics i didn't need to
you know what i mean do you um
do you mind what what substance
specifically would were you struggling
with
opiates opiate and and i'm curious
how did it start with a prescription
from a doctor or how did it start
yeah i actually had a i had a sports
injury in high school
and um i was first prescribed percocet
and
um and i was i was a nerd in high school
so i i
thought i would freak out if i smoked it
um but opiates were the first thing that
i took
that gave me that feeling of i don't
have to think about my problems
it was the absence of pain so um
so that's that's where all that came
from and it was right at the beginning
i'm 27 now
yeah it was right at the beginning of
the opiate crisis um
and so with the legal prescription you
got hooked and then it continued after
you no longer needed them for
the injury oh yeah the obsession had
begun
that whole wheel started turning of
well if this worked this way if one is
good too is better
yeah right um right and uh and if i
if that helped with that pain then maybe
from trauma and things like that that i
experienced in my life that i had never
identified before um
maybe these other things will work and
for
people who hear this and say well
why couldn't you just start weaning
yourself off slowly like
it just doesn't work that way does it
no no well because you're no it's you're
not dealing with the drugs it doesn't
have anything to do with the drugs
the drugs are just the most um
highlighted part
of the problem right right like like
because we all
experience vices in our life whether
it's with money or sex or power
you know what i mean but uh but that
that is the easiest way for someone with
an addictive personality
um because it's instifu it's instantly
gratifying
right um just like spending spending
money on a pair of shoes that you didn't
really want to begin with right you just
want to hear that kaching sound
yep um and so uh so yeah that's kind of
it's it's not as simple as just quit but
i understand why people say that because
explaining to addiction to a
quote-unquote like to a person who's
never dealt with it is almost like
explaining
yellow to a blind person like it's
really difficult even if they really
want to understand even if they love you
or respect you um so that and that's
partially been my job as well is to is
to talk to these representatives and
things like that about that
and get them to understand um
you know why it is that people do need
help why they need those resources and
they need
um some attention you know what i mean
absolutely william well said
um no thank you thank you for calling in
i appreciate it
thank you so much sir all right take
care we're gonna go to a quick break if
you are holding don't hang up because
we'll go right back to the phones after
this short break
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
let's get back to the phones at
617-830-4750 and see what's on people's
minds let's go to our caller from the
785 area code 785 has been a very
controversial area code for the show we
have a long history with it
um who's calling today from 785 today
is that me yeah who's this hey david
um my name is brad i'm a senior
in at a at a high school in the 785
region i don't
i'm new to watching you so i'm not
familiar with all the controversies
regarding my area code well let me just
put it this way
clearly you are not the kansas troll so
we can just skip any other discussions
and move on to what what you want to
talk about yeah
all right cool um i've got two questions
i don't know if that's too much but
please um so we have youtube twitch like
a bunch of
a variety of internet media now and
as far as i can tell with the type of
crowd i hang out with which is
a mix of right wingers and left wingers
um
a lot of young kids are being like
i don't want to be indoctrinated but are
being
fed a lot of abstract political theory
at a very young age and i heard you say
or actually i looked i looked at a
article about you that
said um you sort of critiqued sanders's
embrace of socialism last year like the
word socialism at least like pure
socialism
not democratic socialism and um do you
think that
that's going that's only a problem
within the older generation being a
a large voting bloc and do you see that
problem that you
pointed out of the word socialism being
embraced going to like end soon
when my generation becomes a big part of
the voting bloc
well you you the answer to that question
is you will be answering that i can't
answer that if you're saying
is your generation going to embrace
actual socialism
i can't answer that for you because it's
up to your generation there's a couple
things i would say
one um the
future of socialism
in the united states is going to be
dictated by
really two primary things one
do the people saying they want it
actually know what it is
and part of the confusion i mean even
when you say socialism versus democratic
socialism
the the real question is socialism
versus social democracy democratic
socialism
as traditionally defined is socialism
what i
think you mean is social democracy in
the sort of northern european style
so the first question is going to be
does the word socialism
get completely redefined to mean social
democracy or are people in your
generation
actually clamoring for socializing the
means of production i mean to ask you
which do you mean when you talk about
socialism
that's a great question um i say a lot
of people who watch a lot of
like theory or read a lot of theory like
sort of are okay with the idea of
socializing
lots of industries like more than just
the resource industries that um
uh that venezuela and norway has done
like oils and stuff
but as as far as like
how they like express their views
through their voting and express their
views through
like political candidates and such i
really only see as
a social democracy being like the only
way to express
like far less um thought now
at least okay so that gets directly into
part two
which is if you are an accelerationist
then your belief would be that the path
to
socialism however you define it is
a sort of breakdown of the current
system that we have
to be rebuilt directly into socialism
my view is an incrementalist view
because
i believe that when you look at history
that's the way that it has worked
and so no matter what your definition of
socialism is whether it is
as far to the center as social democracy
or as far to the left as you know
marxist leninism or whatever whatever it
may be
yeah um the next step i believe is
social democracy either way
so the immediate question is is the
entire
left that is at social democracy and
further left going to unite
around social democracy because i think
we should all recognize
no matter what we see as the end point
that's the next stop on the train so to
speak
most definitely yeah um
i have one more question hopefully this
doesn't take too much time sure
but my question is is there any
political
um issue today that you believe um
some sort of violence is justified
for example like the rioters are would
you say they're justified in
property damage even though it's not
like all of them who are doing it
obviously as some right-wing pundits uh
try to make out the picture to be like
is there any structural issue in society
that you believe
the only way to get a large majority of
americans to like pay attention and wake
up to
um is through political violence to get
that message on tv
okay so this is a really big topic and a
great question let me say a few things
about it
first of all i'm gonna stop short of
like moralizing whether whether it's
morally justified to turn to violence to
achieve
political means right now i want to stop
because that's just a kind of a matter
of opinion
where i i'm going to kind of take it
from a more pragmatic perspective
number one the question i would ask is
have
other means short of violence been tried
because if they haven't i think that we
should be trying those first
and as an example mass rallies in urban
centers
strategic defaults to [ __ ] the
financial system
strategic work call outs there's a whole
list of things i give in my
my videos that i've done about how
activism can be more effective than
signing a petition and calling your rep
that have not been tried yet and so for
me from a pragmatic perspective i would
try those things
first before i go to violence because
there's a smaller risk to the
individuals doing them
the second part is from a practical
perspective
you can look at old videos of malcolm x
and martin luther king
weighing in on this issue i am much more
pragmatically aligned with martin luther
king who said
even if you can morally justify the
violence
in practice it very often ends up
hurting the very people
who we on the left are trying to help
through the violence and so i also don't
want
to suggest people do things which may
actually
most hurt those we are trying to help so
i don't know if that's an answer i'm not
answering the morality part of it but i
hope
i hope i'm giving you a perspective on
the practicality of it
yeah oh no that was a great answer it's
just that there's a there's just a huge
conversation
like whether um i mean there was a book
released 10 years ago called the new jim
crow that's like
a huge critique of the criminal justice
system now and it seems
like but not a lot has um changed policy
wise like
i don't i don't know if you saw the ad
um i believe it was earlier this year
but it was like trump
thing he passed major criminal justice
reform which is a joke
but yeah it's
yeah i was just i was just wondering
what your thoughts are on that topic i'm
a new viewer i haven't seen too much of
your videos but
i'm watching now so well i'm glad to
have you and uh
you're thinking about a lot of important
issues and i appreciate you calling in
yep you have a good one all right take
care uh okay
that is going to do it for live calls
for this week as always i do have to
apologize i throw myself at your mercy i
was not able to get to every caller
but we will take calls again and i hope
to hear from you next time we'll take a
quick break and be back with more show
right after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to
keep us going is through patreon where
you can pledge as little as
one dollar per month or as much as you
want
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
great perks and benefits as well read
about them
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the audience questions have been pouring
in sort of like a fire hose and maybe
not surprisingly as we get closer to the
november election more and more
of the questions relate to the election
but not all of them the first one i got
is
how much of america will refuse the
coronavirus vaccine and
will this prevent us from getting to
herd immunity this is it's really an
empirical question it's not
i mean we can speculate about motives
and we can look at polling to figure out
part of the answer but part of this is
an empirical question in terms of
will we get to that magic number that we
need
uh in order to reach herd immunity now
herd immunity there's a little bit of
confusion about hurt immunity there are
folks who
email me and i can tell that they don't
realize
the level of immunity to reach herd
immunity
depends on the disease so if a disease
is much
more contagious like for example measles
which has an
r value of somewhere between 16 and 18
i'm going from memory here
measles is so contagious it spreads so
easily where it can be
aerosolized where you go into an
elevator
after someone has already left the
elevator and they might have been
carrying it and you could catch it
it's a huge level of contagion far more
than coronavirus or the flu
it's so contagious that you need like 95
immunity to reach herd immunity which is
why it's so important that everybody be
vaccinated against measles
when the condition is less contagious
when the disease is less contagious
um like coronavirus which is more
contagious than flu but far less
contagious than measles
the level of immunity required for herd
immunity is lower and
the estimates are that for coronavirus
it's about 70
rather than measles is 95 because
coronavirus spreads less easily than
measles
so we need to get to 70 now you can get
to that
through a combination of naturally
acquired immunity from people who have
recovered from the disease
and immunizations people who have been
vaccinated
now there's an open question as to how
long you are
immune after recovering from coronavirus
we don't know the answer to that yet but
hypothetically you could get your
seventy percent
if five percent of the population has
recovered
naturally from coronavirus and
two-thirds you know 66 percent
get vaccinated that gets you 71 you you
are at herd immunity
the sad reality of the situation is that
we have two polls
one from right around june one and one
from july one roughly
where only about half of americans say
they plan to get the vaccine
there's an ap norc poll from may 27
where 50 of americans say they would get
a coronavirus vaccine
and then june 30th on different poll
which says
that again about 50 percent of americans
plan to get the vaccine now
it's been five weeks since that latest
poll it's conceivable that because of
the continued
spread deaths back up to fifty you know
a thousand 1 1200 1500 a day
that more people are now planning to get
the vaccine now this is simple math
if you need 70 and half plan to get the
vaccine
to get to herd immunity that means you
need an additional 20
of the country to recover naturally 20
of the country is about 66 million
people
uh that would imply a 660
000 person death toll
estimating roughly one percent of those
who get the virus die
now that's the simple math the reality
is
when you look at more complex and
detailed
contagion models um you don't
literally need 70 in for this reason and
i want to try to explain this
correctly um you aren't
re you don't come into contact with
everybody
in the country so in reality
your risk of contagion is not so much
about
is the country level at a country level
do we have 70
immunity but it's more related to what's
going on in your immediate
surroundings and because we have
dramatically different urban versus
rural or rural
as trump says situations in the united
states
you probably would get a a practical
practically speaking
herd immunity somewhere short of 70
because not the entire population is not
regularly coming into contact with the
entire population you're mostly coming
into contact with
some limited group of people when you're
going to work when you're going to your
grocery store etc and so the
the real number is a little short of 70
but regardless
if only half the country plans to get
the vaccine we need 20
to get the virus in order to reach herd
immunity and that means a lot of people
are going to die that would be another
500 000 people compared to where we are
right now
very very ugly i hope that it's not the
case i hope people change their minds
but the polling so far is extremely
disturbing
next question today david if trump does
delay the the election
can you tell me definitively who becomes
president i've heard nancy pelosi
i've heard chuck grassley i don't really
understand okay so this came up briefly
in a voicemail earlier this week but
let's go through it again
uh if donald trump delays the election
enough
and again i i'm not debating here
whether he can do it how it could be
done
how much he would i don't want to do
that stuff because there's all sorts you
know the
the electors have to vote i believe it's
in the first half of december
and there's other dates and elections
are run by the states these are 50 state
decisions more than they are anything
that donald trump would do
so let's skip that piece for now but
let's imagine we get to january 20th
and there has not been an election trump
doesn't stay in power
trump stops being the president now when
you look at the line of succession
okay it would go from president to vice
president but mike pence also would no
longer be vice president
well then it would go to the speaker of
the house nancy pelosi well
if the election in california doesn't
happen
she is no longer elected so
she's no longer speaker of the house so
it would skip her
so eventually it would go to the senate
pro
tem now currently the senate pro tem
is chuck grassley a republican because
republicans have the majority
in the senate but the problem is that 35
senate seats are up for election in
november of the hundred senate seats
if those 35 elections don't happen
again we're assuming none of the
elections happen you might have some
states do the election but not enough
to select the president but let's skip
that for now
if those 35 senate seats end up being
open you now only have 65 senators
and that means that the democrats would
have a majority because republicans have
far more
seats to defend in november than do
democrats so if none of these 35
elections happen
republicans lose more seats than
democrats you then have
no president no vice president no house
but you have a senate made up of the 65
remaining senators who are more than 50
percent democrats meaning democrats get
to select a senate pro tem
who becomes the president until this is
resolved now historically
again this is our best understanding
producer pat and i have been researching
this this is our best understanding
historically senate pro tem tends to go
to the most senior
senator from the party right now that's
vermont's patrick leahy
however it's conceivable that if the 65
remaining senators knew
that by electing a senate pro tem they
were essentially
selecting the next president it's
conceivable they would pick someone
other than patrick leahy but
that's the scenario as i best understand
it today
that would determine who is president if
we don't have a presidential election in
november now
let me go back to what i said when i
commented on james clyburn earlier this
week saying i think trump is going to
after he loses you some kind of
emergency to stay in power
i believe that our coverage of that
possibility
needs to focus around the idea that the
mere suggestion of delaying a federal
election which has never happened
is a despotic authoritarian dystopian
nightmare
um the the now that we
i was asked the question what exactly
would happen i've answered it to the
best of my ability i don't think that's
where the focus should be the focus
should be
that trump even floating this idea is
completely outrageous
we vote in this country we figure out
how to do it states are expanding
absentee ballot access
universal absentee voting as i'm calling
it uh
and we're going to have an election and
donald trump is going to either win
or not win and things are going to
happen on the schedule they're supposed
that has to be the default conversation
once you start engaging in what would
justify delaying it or what would be the
mechanism for delaying it
academically it's interesting but it's
problematic when
it becomes a corporate media dialogue
which only legitimizes the idea at its
core so
that that's my take on that hey david
are anti-trump
republicans sort of a third party now
will they become a formal third party
going forward
my instinct is no and i know that a lot
of you have been following very closely
groups like the lincoln project which
are made up mostly
of disaffected republicans who believe
that the republican party under donald
trump is not really the republican party
uh of of pre-donald trump which is true
in many senses
um and and uh could this split off could
this permanently fracture the republican
party
i think the answer is no and it's no for
a couple of different reasons
number one if the republican party
for more formally fractures and you've
got sort of like the trumpian
republicans and then more traditional
pre-trump republicans it helps democrats
dramatically because it splits the
right-wing vote
republicans know this and so it would be
dealing a huge amount of self-inflicted
damage if the democratic party doesn't
split
a split in the republican party destroys
the possibilities of many republicans
from getting reelected so on a practical
level i don't think they're going to do
it
but there's another reason which is that
until i see evidence otherwise
these groups like the lincoln project
and other anti-trump republicans mitt
romney etc this is temporary if biden
wins things go back to the way they were
in terms of their opposition to
democratic policy democratic ideas even
when the democratic ideas are only
marginally more
left than the mainstream republican
ideas as they are in some cases
the lincoln project is it's a
pre-trump republican party and
that means that it is um immediately
going to go back to saying
what joe biden wants to do is bad joe
biden building a climate proposal on the
green new deal is bad joe biden wanting
to
uncap social security earnings and
eliminate the
stepped-up basis clause and all of the
they're against all of that stuff and so
but my my belief is that this ends
as soon as soon as uh
donald trump is out of office now
there's one sort of caveat to this
um a lot of these anti-trump republicans
have said they aren't going to go back
to the republican party
that the the idea being they've burnt
their bridges that by opposing donald
trump
they've also ruined relationships with
some of the more
uh traditional mainstream republicans
who are falling in line with trump and
that that's an irreparable relationship
number one history tells us otherwise
politics makes strange bedfellows
grudges that seem um uh
un unforgivable so to speak end up being
forgiven either explicitly or implicitly
and those same alliances end up being
formed so i just don't believe
that the the bridges have been burned
permanently the bridges can be rebuilt
but number two you can be out of the
republican party in some kind of strict
technical sense and still oppose
democrats and still end up voting for
future
republican candidates so i it's it's
partly that i don't believe them but
partly it's it could be a technicality
now
in terms of my view i would love
multiple parties and i would love a
different voting system i've said before
the best path to empowering
parties other than republicans and
democrats in the united states
involves serious campaign finance reform
number one
and number two a different voting system
than first past the post because for as
long as we continue to have per
first pass the post the spoiler effect
of supporting a third party candidate is
too great
if i love the green party
and then would vote democratic and
really don't want a republican
i risk putting the republican in office
by voting for the green party
if on the right i'm actually you know
i don't know some far-right neo-nazi and
i want david duke
but if it's not david duke i'd prefer
trump and i really don't want joe biden
if i vote for david duke if he were
running i actually
risk putting joe biden in office so
we've talked about that
before i'm not going to delve into that
in more detail now but i i would prefer
multiple parties i would rather do away
with the two-party duopoly
i've i'm very interested in proportional
representation systems the likes of
which we have
uh we see in other countries although i
understand the risks of that and i'm not
ignoring them but until we do campaign
finance reform
and have something other than a
first-past-the-post system unless we go
in the direction of proportional
and and really think through what that
would look like uh
we're going to see the two-party duopoly
maintain
and uh that is an unfortunate reality
that we have to contend with
we have a tremendous bonus show for you
today
get instant access to it instant
by becoming a member at joinedpakman.com
or becoming a patron
at patreon.com davidpakmanshow
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor
is blinkist the app that lets you read
or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video